una asociación sin límites entre Rusia y
china Así calificaron el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin y el ministro de defensa
chino lichanfó la cooperación militar
entre ambas naciones en un encuentro
formal en el que también participó el
jefe de la cartera de defensas rusa
Putin destacó el nivel de los
intercambios con su principal Aliado
Los lazos están mejorando en todas las
vías en la economía en el área social
educativa y cultural y estamos
trabajando activamente a nivel de los
ministerios de defensa compartimos
regularmente información útil cooperamos
en el campo militar y colaboración
técnica
en este sentido un alto funcionario
ucraniano denunció el pasado viernes el
hallazgo de componentes chinos en el
armamento ruso utilizado en Ucrania
aunque los principales aliados de kiev
Estados Unidos y la otan afirmaron que
no ven indicio alguno la visita tiene
lugar mientras
Moscú y Beijing avanzan en ejercicios
conjuntos en el lejano Oriente ruso a
pesar de alto nivel de integración china
aboga por un cc de las hostilidades en
Ucrania una posición que manifestó en un
documento de 12 puntos entre los que se
encuentran el respeto a la soberanía de
las Naciones el cese de las hostilidades
la resolución de la crisis humanitaria
el freno de las sanciones unilaterales y
la protección de los prisioneros de
guerra durante las recientes visitas de
los mandatarios de Francia y Brasil a
Beijing el presidente chino
defendió el diálogo y un acuerdo
político como la salida correcta a la
guerra